mr miliband is this new announcement on
housing an actual manifesto commitment
because it's not in the manifesto
absolutely and it's on our pledge card
it's our sixth pledge and I think it's
so important I think it goes to the big
argument of this election do we build a
country that works for working people
again or do we have a country that what
just works for the richest and most
powerful and I think housing and the
failure to build homes is one of the big
signs of that and the failure to help
first-time buyers and that's why I'm
proud of our announcement to say
there'll be no stamp duty payable on
homes up to 300,000 pounds for
first-time buyers for three years under
a Labour government so the stamp duty
announcement I just want to clarify this
it isn't actually in your manifesto and
these documents have a certain
importance constitutionally easy to
manifesto commit yes you can hold me to
it okay well we will we will okay on
housing now you made much of the
coalition record on house building on
that's house building completions on
starts it's the Labour government in
which you were a cabinet minister that
had the record low of 88,000 in England
for housing starts partly because of the
financial crisis but at the time York of
that government had promised two or
three hundred thousand a year we so why
should we believe you now when you've
Gordon Brown made the same promise in
his seventh we didn't do enough the last
ever government didn't do it off but my
contention to Paislee this government
isn't doing enough either and when
you've got a situation where it's the
worst record on home but home building
since the 1920s we know we have to act
and it's us I have a comprehensive plan
recognized in the housing field the
Lions plan a comprehensive plan to build
200,000 homes a year and not just build
homes but to help first-time buyers as
we're outlining today so I think the
reality is that no government for a
generation has really got to grips with
the issues that we face in housing but
the government I lead if I'm elected on
major 7th will do sir sewage a thousand
homes a year in England we have
have that since 1980 now it doesn't seem
like there's a radical change in policy
on supply or planning when that required
building on the greenbelt I don't see
that in the manifesto let me set out
what we're going to do first of all
we're going to break the hold of some of
the developers so we're going to say
that developers can't simply sit on land
and wait for it to accumulate in value
even when it has planning permission
will give councils paths they use the
land or lose the land secondly I think
the change we're making relation to
planning permission which is to say that
when planning permission is granted
local councils can set aside the housing
for people who've lived in the area for
up to fifty percent of the housing but
we've lived in the area for up to three
years will unblock some of the local
skepticism about building homes we're
going to give loans to some of the small
developers who don't feel they have
access to the market so it's a pretty
comprehensive plan it's been worked
through with the housing sector by
Michael Lyons it's a plan i'm proud of
and it's a plan i believe will deliver
on the stamp duty cart I mean you're an
economist you know that a stamp duty
count will just result in higher house
prices no it depends what you do in
relation to supply and that's why the
two things come together the cut in
stamp duty the the fact that zero stamp
duty will be charged on homes up to
300,000 pounds the first time buyers for
three years combined with the plan to
build homes you've always got to act on
both of these things you got to act on
demand and if you like making things
more affordable but also or making sure
you build the homes so house prices
aren't out of reach and it's the two
that come together but I think it's such
an important part of our plan today when
you look back though I mean the big
question mark in the country as regards
labor and trust in you ten days ahead of
a period when you might become Prime
Minister is that record and we've had
focused apologies and I'm not trying to
get you to say sorry has labor learnt
the lesson of things like a trebling in
real house prices that's the cause of
the unaffordability do you accept that
that the trebling of real house prices
under labour was a problem and not a
glorious vote winning
glory to the United Kingdom we didn't
build enough homes definitely you're
right we didn't build it I was a
trebling of house price is a problem for
97 people I certainly think the fact
that house prices get out of reach for
people was a problem and it remains a
problem under this government you know
we're talking about house prices now
that I think are on average eight times
the average wage and the question people
have to ask at this election feisal is
who's really going to make a difference
on these issues you know I think this
housing is you goes to this wider
question about what kind of country we
want to be who do we want to be run for
do we want to be a country that puts
working people first my plan for the
country or do we want more of the same
of what David Carroll what about emily's
you've gone about speculators and
landlords I think 30 plus Labour MPs are
by to let animals should they not be by
to let landlords well we're not trying
to stop anyone being a buy-to-let
landlord we want good landlords but i
think the proposal that we announced
yesterday is an important proposal which
is to say that when landlords get tax
relief for example for wear and tear on
accommodation we should make sure that
that housing is a decent standard I a
new we want stability a greater
stability for people in the private
rented sector you know it's really
interesting this think about what I said
yesterday about three year tendencies
not one year tendencies with predictable
rent changes in those three years based
on the rate of inflation Conservative
Party have no art so they've got no
answer today on our housing proposal
they had no answer yesterday and that's
because I think they don't really have
answers to the central problems that
working people are facing in our country
and in terms of the other lessons and
clearly the ifs it's not just about
house building you always say that the
thing that you apologize for in terms of
Labor's records is what happened in the
banking sector and do not accept that
the total failure to regulate the
banking sector had an impact on the
fiscal deficit that the two things go
together you can't separate those things
out and that was neighbors fault well
you're absolutely right that the
financial crisis is what caused high
deficits all around the world and you're
absolutely right about the chain of
events so it was failure to regulate the
banks which was socially which is lame
is where we made a mistake along with
governments around the world I mean the
David Cameron was urging
less regulation but leave that to one
side indeed called deficits around the
world President Obama is still dealing
with that governments all around the
world and in with the question for this
election though is who's going to get
the deficit down who's going to do it in
a fair way now I think we've got the
sensible balanced plan you've got some
people are saying no cuts got David
Cameron who wants to double the cuts
next year which will have terrible
effect on our NHS and other public
services we've got a sensible balanced
plan cutting the deficit every year and
balancing the books but it's consistent
with a 90 billion pound deficit by 2020
over a decade after the crisis that's
what the ifs say I don't share that view
and let me explain why we want to run a
surplus on the current budget that's our
fiscal rule that's our commitment
cutting the deficit every year and
having net debt falling as soon as
possible in the next parliament it's
okay it's vague you have a lot of
wriggle room that they don't need to
borrow more it's a clear timetable it's
the right time table and you know the
difference with our manifesto is that
there are no commitments which require
additional borrowing not on current or
capital and what a contrast Beisel with
the Conservative Party who are flinging
around commitments on the National
Health Service on tax cuts on the right
to buy on rail without any idea where
the where the money's coming from I
think that's one of the interesting
things about this campaign is that
you've seen the Conservative Party
flinging around commitments without a
sense of where the money's coming from
and labour where everything is costed
and it's clear where the money's coming
your ex cabinet colleague Peter
Mandelson has a little private
consultancy and he's in that a written
and noticed global Council saying that
the SNP would push a Labour government
to the left and result in higher public
spending your ex cabinet colleague its
own consultancy said that well that's
not right because I'm absolutely clear
we're going to stick to our plans on the
deficit I'm working for a majority
labour government but we are sticking to
our plan for the deficit we're going to
get the deficit down every year we're
going to balance the books we're going
to run a surplus on the current budget
and absolutely clear on this issue of
housing though it's in English devolved
issue we have separate policies in
Scotland surely it could not be right
that Scottish MPs would also have a say
on an issue like the one you're talking
about today on housing and stamp duty
well if you're asking me to rewrite the
way the House of Commons works on the
back of an envelope I'm not going to do
that because I think our Constitution
and our United Kingdom is too important
to play games with that's David
Cameron's approach that's what he's done
ever since sep tember the 19th of last
year so the approach i'll take is have a
proper constitutional convention to look
at all of these issues between the
mineral oil invention with the sm being
be included in that constitutional will
we've said will include all the nations
and regions of the United Kingdom it's
not so much about specific parties it's
about the nations and regions of our
country in a constitutional convention
on that same issue do you feel that
Scott has the issue of Scotland and the
rise of the SNP the latest poll suggests
you could be wiped out entirely
fifty-four percent is anything but let's
see what happens on whether seven you
know I take an old-fashioned view on
this I think there are ten days to go
till this general election the people
will make their decision soon enough I
think for people in Scotland there's a
clear choice a road to a second
referendum which is what the SNP want
they used to say it was once in a
lifetime once in a generation not
anymore they want a second referendum in
the next five years I think that's wrong
it's not my plant it's not what I want
or a labor plan for a road to a fairer
economy and really you're going to
either end up with a Labour government
or Tory government after this election
I'd urge everyone in Scotland to vote
Labour because I don't the people in
Scotland want another conservative
government I'd urge them to vote Labour
for our economy would it be legitimate
for the leader of a second place party
to become Prime Minister you're inviting
me into in fear most alike in fear
though still I'm not talking about you
speculation you know I'm going to
concentrate on saying to people setting
out the choice to people between now and
may the seven I'm taking up two major
seventh at 10pm this is such a
consequential such an important election
for the British people this is their
time this is once in a five years choice
this choice doesn't come along very
often and I'm urging them to choose
labor are you comfortable with the idea
that in two weeks you could have your
finger on the nuclear button
I'm ready to be Prime Minister and I'm
ready for the responsibilities of that
entails and I believe that in this
campaign we've set out a plan a plan for
working people here at home but also a
plan for Britain to be strong and
confident in the world are you a person
who could accept the idea the decisions
that you make might incidentally cause
civilian deaths in the name of national
security can you accept that trade off
I'm not gonna I'm not going to enter
hypothetical things about what I might
face as prime minister but I can say
this to you I'm ready for what the job
entails and I'm ready for all the
difficult decisions that the job entails
including matters of peace and war and
I've shown in this Parliament the
approach that I'll take the approach
that I'll take on issues like Libya
where I supported the government's
decision to work with other countries
and to intervene and on Syria where in
the summer of 2013 I said no so I'm
ready for the decisions that the job of
Prime Minister entails well that's
question about the the nature of the
campaign and certainly there's a
contrast you haven't been on the SNP
campaign or the obviously or the UK
campaign they're much more comfortable
much freer walking the streets all that
sort of stuff forgive me but with both
mr. Cameron's campaign in your campaign
things are a little sterile in these
types of theaters do you not want to get
out there and actually meet the people
rather than just labor active you know
that is what I do and you know look
tomorrow I'm going to be in Wales and
I'm gonna be doing what we call a
people's question time where we invite
people who are not labour supporters to
come and talk to us to persuade people
so I absolutely i'm getting out there
and talking to people about a whole
range of things and you know I'm
somebody who throughout this campaign
has been taking questions from members
of the public and setting out the big
choice I think that's what people want
the big choice and also big ideas to
change the country you know what we're
talking about in housing today what
we're going to do if we get elected in
10 days time is about changing the
country so it works for working people
and I'm pleased about the way we're
laying out that choice before people in
this campaign thank you very much for
thank you